[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a french romantic comedy drama
film called we die young spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
fourteen-year-old lucas lives in
washington dc and works as a collector
for a gang called the ms-13 since he is
young and looks fairly innocent the gang
uses him to collect deaths and deliver
illegal substances in guarded areas in
an opening monologue lucas explains the
ins and outs of the gang and the way it
functions there are more than 10 000
ms-13 members in over 40 states their
influence ranges from business to
politics but their main source of income
is the illegal trade of recreational
drugs the lowest rank of the gang is the
blue boys who are in charge of selling
they give the money to the collectors
which is then handed to the second
highest gang member jester at last the
money goes to the merciless gang leader
rincon he makes every decision for the
group and is a god to the members of the
gang lucas is merely a collector but
works closely with rincon the friendship
between them is not liked by the
right-hand man jester he knows that
rincon favors the kid more than him this
makes his blood boil because he has
worshipped rincon since the beginning of
the gang one afternoon lucas collects
the money from the blue boys and brings
it to the leader he witnesses some
gangsters beating a man to death for
refusing to pay the money he owes seeing
people being murdered is a usual day for
the kid then we are introduced to a mute
afghanistan war veteran named daniel
lucas's customers consist of several
people from street junkies to high
profile individuals but out of all of
them daniel stands out the most unlike
most people who consume pills for fun he
does so to block an unsolved trauma he
works at a local car shop and helps
lucas whenever he can for the past few
days rincon is stressed because an fbi
car has been parked outside his house
keeping an eye on him because of this
the business has been going very slow
moreover rincon's sister gabriela's
wedding is in a few days and they are
celebrating from home she is handicapped
so rincon wants to do everything in his
power to make the day special while
collecting money that day lucas meets an
old shopkeeper who is a few hundred
short because his wife is sick if it had
been any other collector they would have
beaten the old man to death but lucas
asks him to pay when he gets the chance
following that he goes to a local junkie
base and finds his little brother miguel
the kid is unaware of the risks of being
in a gang and wants to be a runner like
his brother lucas wants the best for him
which is why he drags him back to the
school somewhere else daniel is with his
friend anna and her daughter he and anna
like each other but have decided to stay
friends since they both have very
different lifestyles as they chat anna
inquires why a man like him lives in a
latino neighborhood daniel says he likes
it here but the truth is he is in
constant need of pills that lucas sells
they help him when he gets panic attacks
and wore flashbacks from the time that
he was in afghanistan the next day
rincon welcomes his soon-to-be
brother-in-law thomas and his family for
the wedding ceremony everyone in the
house is preparing for the occasion so
he has to entertain the in-laws on his
own the gangster is not very good at
holding social conversations so when
lucas arrives with the money he is happy
to get out of this situation when he and
lucas are alone he counts the money
happy that he has someone as trustworthy
as lucas working by his side taking the
opportunity the kid asks him to leave
his little brother out of the business
rincon agrees and gives him a suit to
wear at the wedding which is in a few
hours but before that there is a very
special task he wants lucas to complete
he has to deliver two packs of illegal
goods to the receiver of a rival gang
this is the most important task lucas
has ever been handed only because anyone
else would be suspected by the fbi
outside the house jester is yet again
not a fan of the idea and thinks the kid
will mess up the deal but he cannot go
against the leader's decision before
dismissing him rincon orders him to
leave lucas's little brother out of the
gang activities outside lucas is on his
way to make the delivery when a kid
informs him that his brother is going
through a jump in it is a process where
everyone gets to beat up a person for 13
seconds and by the end of it the person
will be a part of the gang lucas tries
to save his little brother but the
others restrain him and proceed to hit
the kid some seconds later they stop and
welcome him to the gang fortunately
miguel is only mildly injured lucas asks
him to come with him just to make sure
he is fine however instead of going to
the tracks to make the delivery he
decides to bring miguel to their house
he doesn't want the kid to stay near the
gang anymore and packs up his bags to
send him to a baseball camp but while
doing so he accidentally drops one of
the packages that rincon had given him
soon he notices that the package is
missing but before he can look for it
jester arrives with his people and asks
him why he isn't at the drop-off point
to save himself lucas claims that rincon
lied to jester about the drop-off point
because he doesn't trust him jester who
was already jealous is furious at the
leader for trusting a kid over him in
the meantime rincon and his sister are
taking wedding pictures and celebrating
the occasion but even when they are
trying to enjoy themselves rincon is
worried about the fbi officers outside
his house jester asks lucas to come to
rincon and explain why he wasn't at the
drop-off track lucas knows that if he
goes to the leader with a missing
package he will surely get killed just
then he sees an old man driving past
them and signals him to crash his car
the man is lucas's associate so he does
as told and distracts jester and his
people taking the opportunity lucas and
miguel run away a chase ensues through
the streets in which the brothers
narrowly avoid the gunshots being fired
at them eventually they meet daniel who
drives them away from the gangsters
suddenly they get into an accident and
the screen goes black a flashback shows
us daniel struggles when he was in
afghanistan he kills several people and
watches his friend get killed by the
enemies back in the present he comes
back to his senses and sees that
miguel's leg is stuck in the seat he
quickly gets out and helps the brothers
before they hide in his room lucas
dresses miguel's wound to the best of
his capabilities while discussing their
next step somewhere else jester goes to
rincon and tells him that lucas has
betrayed them and run away with the
packages rincon is shocked because he
trusted the kid more than his closest
mates if they do not deliver the
packages they will surely be attacked by
the rival cartel and the wedding will be
ruined alongside the loss in business
since he has to be at the wedding he
orders jester to bring lucas and the
packages at any cost lucas on the other
hand knows that the only way for him to
survive is by handing rincon both the
packages he goes through the bags and
sees that the second one is missing as
well upon realizing that it must have
dropped in the car he rushes to the
crash site back at the house a man named
spider crashes the wedding he is the
rival dealer who is supposed to receive
the packages rincon doesn't want a guy
like him at a family occasion but he has
to ask him to wait for a while meanwhile
lucas reaches the burning car and
discovers the second package inside on
looking closer he notices that it is
full of cash which is also in flames it
is clear that he is not getting out of
this situation alive but all he cares
about is his brother's well-being he
runs back to daniel and thanks him
daniel wants to drive them out of the
city but lucas says they do not need any
more of his help following that the
brothers rushed to their apartment to
get the first package lucas wants to run
away from the city using the money in
the package the brothers wait outside
the apartment for most of the day
because it is swarming with rincon's men
a while later when no one from the gang
is around they sneak inside but right
then they are caught by a kid who is
also a budding gang member he says that
he will keep his mouth shut since he has
known them forever but as the brothers
are about to leave with the money the
kid brings jester in he holds the
brothers at gunpoint and checks lucas's
bag finding out that one of the packages
is missing lucas tells him that the
package is burned into ashes which
doesn't help jester's anger some hours
later daniel returns to work to find
that the gangsters have assaulted the
owner of the shop an enraged anna blames
him for the old man's condition it turns
out that jester and the gangsters were
there to look for the second package
which is why the owner was beaten after
discovering that the kids have been
caught daniel decides to risk his life
to get them out of there safely anna
tries to convince him otherwise but she
cannot persuade him to abort his plan in
the meantime rincon's sister gets
married and the newlyweds kiss lucas and
miguel are brought to the house by
jester he keeps them waiting until
rincon gets done with the ceremony
outside in the kitchen one of
gabriella's friends is preparing drinks
for the guests all of a sudden spider
starts touching her inappropriately some
time later rincon enters the kitchen and
sees him assaulting his sister-like
friend in a fit of rage the gangster
beats spider to death and asks the girl
to clean the blood outside daniel
arrives and threatens two guards they
get into a fight which ends in the death
of one of the guards daniel holds the
other hostage and thinks of a plan he
knows that he cannot just walk in and
save the boys what he needs is a
distraction hence he brings the hostage
in front of the fbi officers the other
gangsters see this and bring their
weapons out when the fbi officers find
out about the guns they call for backup
and soon a shootout starts ringcone
meets lucas and asks him where the other
package is but before he can answer
gunshots are heard the wedding is
interrupted by a dead body dropping out
of the window everyone starts running
for their lives which causes chaos
daniel is spotted and shot in the leg
but he somehow manages to get the boys
he ties miguel's jacket around his wound
before bringing them outside to rincon's
dismay his sister is also shot and
killed in the shootout daniel lucas and
miguel are now on a railway track nearby
jester catches up to them and orders
them to hand over the second package it
turns out daniel stole it amidst the
shootout suddenly daniel falls to the
ground because of the injury and rincon
arrives at the same time he is
devastated by his sister's death and
blames the kids for the mishap but to
everyone's surprise he asks the brothers
to run away and never come back to dc
again jester is beyond shocked he
believes that rincon is no longer fit to
run the gang so he shoots him dead then
he asks for the package one more time
daniel throws miguel his jacket and
hands the package to jester the boys use
this opportunity to run away however
jester soon finds out that the package
is empty he is ready to kill daniel when
the gangster kid who ratted them out
earlier shoots him in the last scene the
brothers are on a train to a new city
miguel finds a bundle of money in his
pocket that they can use to start a
better life together subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching